Великі міста – це завжди багато бетону й асфальту.
Які перекривають відтік дощовій воді.
Опадів останнім часом стає дедалі більше
і вода часто не вміщується у каналізацію для злив.
Наприкінці червня Берлін пережив катастрофічну зливу.
За добу в місті випала чотиримісячна норма води.
Каналізацію переповнило.
Лише у кількох районах міста не сталося повені
там, де реалізована концепція "міста-губки".
Вона передбачає акумуляцію опадів зеленими насадженнями
й водоймами, а не відведення дощової води у каналізацію.
Як, наприклад, у районі Потсдамерплац.
Тут практично вся дощова вода стікається у це штучне озеро.
Це частина великого проекту
з адаптації мегаполіса до змін клімату.
А в офісі міського підприємства з водопостачання
можна побачити й інший приклад «міста-губки»
Мох і трава всмоктують воду, розвантажуючи каналізацію.
“Озеленені дахи відіграють велику роль,
оскільки злива, як правило, триває не дуже довго.
І вода спочатку залишається на озелененому даху,
а потім поволі стікає.
Тобто навантаження на каналізацію знижується"
Але це не єдиний плюс.
«З іншого боку – і це теж важливо!
озеленені дахи охолоджують місто в спеку.
Вони попереджають перегрів.
Тому що вода, яку дах увібрав у себе, випаровується.”
Інженер-гідролог Гайко Зікер
розробляє концепції використання дощової води
для мегаполісів та будівельних фірм.
За його словами, відносно проста й недорога технологія
"губки" складна з точки зору планування.
“З точки зору планування, це дуже складно,
тому що потрібен простір.
А в містах, і особливо в центрі,
площа – дуже дороге задоволення.
Це означає, що ця територія конкурує
з дитячими майданчиками, із зеленими насадженнями.
Добрі рішення - це ті, що інтегрують різні функції,
тобто так звані мультифункціональні майданчики.”
Гідролог каже, що розуміння проблеми
приходить найшвидше до тих, хто постраждав від повеней.
«Ніхто, звичайно, не хоче цих злив.
Але досвід показує, що певний поштовх іде
від суспільства і місцевого керівництва після таких злив.
Спочатку завжди має статися якась катастрофа,
аби на неї відреагували.»
Аби скоротити ризик повеней,
міська влада Берліна найближчим часом створить
агенцію "дощової води" для заохочення
будівництва за принципом "міста-губки".